[Musik]
marvin geilich der ist geschäftsführer
von der veranstaltungstechnik fürmann
nicos hier in berlin gebunden morgen
herr geilich wir sprechen immer so ein
bisschen abstrakt über die korona folgen
in der deutschen wirtschaft bei ihnen
sind die ganz konkret vielleicht
schildern sie einmal inwieweit ihnen das
geschäft jetzt in den vergangenen zwei
wochen schon weggebrochen ist die
deutsche veranstaltungswirtschaft steht
quasi schon still konferenzen sind
abgesagt über 90% bis in den mai rein
jetzt nach den neuen vorschlägen auch
veranstaltungen über 1000 personen ab
zusagen wird die lage härter dafür
konferenz stattfinden
die situation schon und das betrifft
nicht nur unser unternehmen sondern
tatsächlich die gesamte branche
die arbeitsplätze ja das
kurzarbeitergeld absenkung des quorums
ist eine sehr gute maßnahme
gleichwohl weiß ich von vielen
unternehmen das die schon stellen
abbauen das sie schon in kurzarbeit
geschickt haben oder ein stück
kurzarbeit schicken müssen weil wir sehr
ja haben sie schon mitarbeiter entlassen
müssen oder haben sie sich schon
entschieden ob sie auf kurzarbeit gehen
wir haben bereits kündigungen
ausgesprochen für mitarbeiter in
probezeit und bereiten kurzarbeit vor
im laufe dieser woche können sie ein
paar zahlen nennen wie dieser einbruch
sich in den vergangenen zwei oder vier
wochen für sie in den büchern deutlich
macht
das können wir relativ einfach wir haben
in den monaten märz bis mai messe und
konferenz saison und wir haben diese so
von september bis november
das heißt es sind diese sechs monaten in
denen unternehmen mit dieser ausrichtung
geld verdienen und zu tun haben
wir haben insgesamt ein auftragseinbruch
von fast 95 prozent
es finden noch einzelne veranstaltungen
statt wir haben zum beispiel die schöne
veranstaltungen auswärtigen abend die
politik sagt also veranstaltungen
bislang nicht in dem maße ab und die
privatwirtschaft schon wir arbeiten mit
zahlreichen
begrenzt hotels principi gegen etwa
vierzig mitarbeiter dann kommt also für
sie die hilfe der regierung jetzt zu
spät für uns kommt die hilfe für uns als
einzelnes unternehmen kommt die hilfe
nicht zu spät weil wir mit digitalen
produkten einiges auffangen können
virtuelle konferenzen realisieren können
aber das gilt für die wenigsten
unternehmen der veranstaltungswirtschaft
ich kann tatsächlich sagen hier herrscht
schon totengräberstimmung und nach und
nach geht das licht aus und das nach
zehn tagen weil die veranstaltung auch
nicht nachgeholt werden also das was
jetzt ausfällt und wir gehen davon aus
bis in den herbst rhein wird nichts
passieren vor der sommerpause nicht mehr
und dann sind auch gar nicht die
kapazitäten da auch allein nicht an
räumen um die projekte nachzuholen das
heißt da wo es bei ausfällen bleiben und
liquiditätshilfen sind genau das was uns
weiterhilft aber eigentlich recht dass
auch noch nicht wir brauchen
rettungsbeihilfen um die krise
abzuwenden
und da bin ich gespannt was für
instrumente dann noch nachgelegt werden
[Musik]